- I mean, I, I, I'm a person
who does her homework a lot.
(intense music)
You already know, my teachers out there.
But, it's just too much.
(upbeat jazzy music)
- Hello, my name is Dylan Jodzik.
I'm 18 years old, I'm
a high school senior.
- Hi, my name is Rachel.
I am 18 years old, I'm
a senior in high school
and today we are going
to react to some TikToks.
- My teacher, Mr Ferroni,
actually is a pretty famous TikToker.
- All my free time, like 90%
of the time I'm on TikTok.
I'm not usually on the teacher side
'cause I don't wanna find my
teacher, who has a TikTok.
- My students never
complete all their homework.
I don't know what to do.
Why are you assigning so much homework?
Why are you overloading
these kids with homework?
Let them rest when they get home.
Don't you want to take a nap?
I'm sure they do too.
- For real!
Yeah, I have some teachers
that assign so much homework.
Do they realize, like, we have, like,
a life outside of school.
- As a senior, 'senioritis'
is a real disease.
Already accepted into college,
why do you guys give me more homework?
We have jobs, I've got sports.
There's other stuff in
our life that we wanna do.
- It's just too much.
I don't know why you're
assigning homework.
We do it in class anyways.
I'll study, I promise.
(giggles)
- I can get it, at the
beginning of the year, you know,
you still have to build
credit and stuff for college.
But by the end of the
year, like, you know,
now we're in April, May,
just, just why even give us homework?
It's usually like, "Oh, why,
homework's not that hard."
Yes, it's not that hard,
but I have 10 other classes.
We're staying home anyway,
like, it's already homework
even though we're at school, technically.
- Hey, why were you absent yesterday?
- [Student] I was at a funeral.
- Oh, I am so sorry for your loss
- [Student] It's okay I
didn't really like the man.
- Oh my gosh.
(giggling)
- Aah, that's really funny.
- I don't know how to comment on that one.
I've definitely had that
excuse where I was, like,
"I'm sick" but I'm really not.
I just wanna sleep in.
Right now with, like, virtual learning
I can't really fake being sick
or I can't really fake being anywhere,
cause they know I'm at home.
- I mean, you go to funerals all the time.
Sometimes for people that you don't know
and at least the teacher took it well,
she wasn't mad or anything.
I'm sure she hears stuff
like that all the time.
- Good morning students,
welcome to another day of online class.
(crosstalk)
So today we're going to
get back into chapter six.
Is there going to any
questions about biomathematics?
- Oh my gosh.
(laughing)
- That's my teacher,
Mr. Feronni.
Mr Feronni.
- I promise you,
He does not dress like that.
That's not even the right room he's in,
he's lying when he makes these tiktoks.
It's really funny,
like, when he tries to make tiktoks
in class and you volunteer to participate
in it and it was like, he'll
be like 'Okay, that was good.'
but he'll be lying to you
because he knows it wasn't good.
But I promise you, Mr. Feronni
is never wearing shorts
and he's never wearing a suit jacket,
but he's always happy to teach us.
And I'm glad to have him as a teacher.
- I remember one time in class,
he was testing to see
who was paying attention.
He would turn off his camera and be like
my connection is not
working and he turned it
on and he has a completely
different shirt on it.
Ended up being like, he changed
his shirt like 11 times.
And he was like, nobody noticed it.
I'm paying attention to the lesson.
Not what you're wearing.
(laughing)
- All right guys.
That's it for today.
Just make sure you
complete your assignment.
It's so great to see you guys.
Have a great day
and I'll see you soon.
- Awh, this one was kind of sad.
- Yeah. I started to notice
like there was one time I stayed
behind just to try to talk
to my teacher about something and
as like all the cameras are going off.
I think that teacher thought I left.
So like I just saw the
teacher like, like 'I'm done.'
I had to like unmute
myself, 'I'm still here.
I'm really sorry.'
And he's like, 'Oh no, no, no, no, no.
That's fine. I'm okay.'
But I think I feel you.
I think I feel the teachers.
- I know Mr Feronni is
being truthfully honest
because I've seen the days
when his Chromebooks acting up
and stuff and he's just
like so upset and so angry.
And my other teachers too,
like they're not getting what
they signed up for to be a teacher.
You know, people got to
think of the teachers too.
I mean, if you think about it,
this is, this is their life.
(laughing)
I've had them in class,
in person and they just
have so much more energy and
so much more like bedazzle.
And it's just like,
you can't convey that over
the screen the same way.
- Yo, Mr. Feronni..
- Do I know you?
- Junior your student
for the last hundred days?
- Honestly, doesn't ring a bell.
- Okay. How about now?
- Oh my God.
Junior. What's up?
- All right.
That's what I mean when Mr. Feronni
is always making us do tiktoks.
I guarantee you that took
them 30 minutes to make.
I went to hybrid school and half
of my teachers didn't know who I was.
You know, I don't blame them
because I'm not really
good with names myself.
- I have terrible eyesight.
I'm going to pause it so I can read it.
(reading the text on the screen)
- Yeah, I mean..
- Yeah, that's crazy.
It's like when you're a kid
and you see your teacher
at the grocery store,
it's like, changes your
whole view on life.
- As a student,
if I go to my teacher, I'll
just be like, I will never
see you other than who
you are in front of me.
If you tell me you like the
same music as me, like cool.
But also that's weird
- I'm going to give these out in
every class in case I
start talking too much.
It's only fair.
All right.
So I'll give it out and you give it
to me and tell me you
think I'm talking too much.
We'll start with junior,
So here you go.
Give it to me anytime I'm
talking to much all right?
Are you serious?
- This is actually the
tiktok, same tiktok idea
that he made me film,
but I never sent him and
I'm still sitting on it.
God, I shouldn't be saying this.
They're going to watch this.
Like sometimes, you know
if my teachers are teaching a lesson
and I already know the
lesson, or I just don't feel
like paying attention, I will mute them.
I'll, I'll put the computer on mute.
And it's a little scary because what
if they call your name?
In real life it's harder to mute someone.
The old fashioned way
is just falling asleep.
- I, I seen the button in the classroom.
I've seen it on the table and
I'm very tempted to take it.
That button on zoom,
oh my, that end button
or like leave button.
So tempting, sometimes who
like I like hover around it
in class.
Like I'll like, I'm like,
I'm going to touch it
but I'm not going to touch it.
I think he's told us this before.
I'm pretty sure America is
going to be at the bottom.
- Teachers. I feel like
are super underpaid.
Some kids spend most of their
day with their teachers.
And you know, if you
have sports and stuff,
that's coaches too, who
are usually also teachers.
When we were actually going to school
like you go to your,
you go to school and you're
there for like six, eight hours.
You go home, you're home
alone for a little bit.
Your parents get home late.
You're with your teacher more
than your parents sometimes.
And you know,
I feel like they're just not
appreciated enough in society.
People don't give them as
much credit as they deserve.
Like, I can name you like a bunch
of good teachers I've
had that have just like
changed my life and made
me the person I am today.
We love teachers.
- That's the one thing I
really started appreciating
during COVID and virtual
and hybrid learning.
Like teachers really do so much
and they sacrifice so much.
And like they're essentially
essential workers.
So we should like treating them like that.
- I know some teachers
who have like second jobs
and it's, it's, I'm not gonna, you know,
I'm not going to call them sad
or anything, but like a lot of
teachers put in way more work
than they need to just to
make sure they're the best
that they can be.
And it's just sad to see
like such a important
job be so undervalued
and so unappreciated.
- And a lot of teachers,
most of my teachers
not even just only Feronni, a lot
of my teachers have gotten
me through this year.
So, you know,
even when you feel a little bummy,
fix that hair, comb
your hair a little bit,
take off the hoodie, you know
get out of bed, like at
least like show your face
or answer a question in
class, for like five minutes
or just one moment so
that you can tell you too
like 'I'm listening, I'm there for you.'
You know.
- If you're a teacher
watching this, get tiktok
if you're not on it, you
know, it's a funny thing.
It's wholesome.
Cause it just shows like, you know,
they're down to try to
connect with their students
and show how they really are and be funny.
(upbeat music)